telling somebody to exercise is an
interesting thing because you mentioned
kind of being almost debilitated almost
completely paralyzed not only by the
physical pain that you had mental but by
being like depressed and that's a tough
situation where there might be some
folks that are overweight they have some
depression and we're saying hey man get
up get up off the couch and go for a
walk and they're like i can't move
they're angry they're like [ __ ] you like
you don't understand why i'm on the
couch you don't get it like if you're a
healthy person and you're sitting down
all day you're like oh my god i gotta
move some people don't have that if
they're not healthy so usually for those
people i say you can start by cutting
things out or at least cut out try and
cut out grains or if you can't do that
cut out the gluten containing grains
just switch over to like keto crackers
or paleo crackers switch over to
drinking water i was so sick i didn't
like water i didn't like the taste of
water is that crazy yes so start small
and don't start necessarily start with
exercise i would start with diet